seltsame dinge geschehen in der
klimaschutz bewegung während weiß
aktivistinnen wie greta team berg und
lisa neubauer omnipräsent sind bleibt
für klimaschützer rinnen mit dunkler
hautfarbe nur die zweite reihe fotos mit
ihnen werden geschnitten oder
aussortiert wie etwa beim anti kohle
protest in datteln 2020 vier jahre nach
dem ersten schulstreik mehren sich daher
die fragen an einer bewegung die
immerhin den anspruch hat für menschen
aus aller welt zu sprechen ist die
europäische klimaschutz bewegung zu weiß
ist files for future am ende sogar
rassistisch ich glaube unsere
gesellschaft ist strukturell rassistisch
und so hart es klingt aber
dementsprechend ist wahrscheinlich
erstmal alles was aus dieser
gesellschaft entsteht irgendwo
strukturell rassistisch und dann
passieren eben solche sachen sagt daria
soto die immerhin eine der sprecherinnen
von fall der sv future ihre eltern
stammen aus dem heutigen iran ihre
persönliche erfahrung dass unter den
demonstrierenden bei future jugendliche
mit migrationshintergrund
unterrepräsentiert sind bestätigen auch
wissenschaftliche studien
war da auch teilweise wirklich so eine
von zwei personen in der gruppe oder
sowas dann auch wieder schwierig ist
wenn man quasi
die stimme ist für eine ganz ganz große
diverse gruppe und so funktioniert es
natürlich auch nicht barea soto de
findet ihren platz bei fff als
studierende beherrscht sie den habitus
einer bewegung die das bild der
freundlichen abiturientin längst zu
ihrem markenkern erhoben hat personen
die anders sind scheinen da zu stören
die bewegung setzt auf eine strategie
der harmlosigkeit
das kommt ja alles zusammen weibliche
menschen gleich haben los dann
akademisch also diese gewählte
kluge ausdrucksweise von weißen menschen
und dann gleichzeitig eben diese diese
vorstellung dass wenn jetzt vielleicht
migrantische menschen psi die bühne
bekommen vielleicht auch mit einer
gewissen
was ja oft dann verurteilt mit einer
gewissen emotionalität auftreten dass
das beides irgendwie
der bewegung schadet dem ruf schadet
freude ist future macht sich die
vorurteile und mechanismen an der
gesellschaft zu nutze die lieber arzt
töchtern zuhört als gastarbeiter kindern
hilfreich um der botschaft gehör zu
verschaffen doch die journalistin jasmin
barek kritisiert dass dieses vorgehen
viele andere menschen ausschließt sie
wünscht sich dass ich nicht nur
moralisch die leute mitnehmen die von
dem thema schon überzeugt sondern
vielleicht auch nachhaltig leben sondern
es haben die massen geht es brauche
menschen die im niedriglohnsektor
arbeiten die in der pflege arbeiten die
gastarbeiter waren
für jasmin m barek ist freut s for
future daher vor allem ein eliten
projekt von und für menschen die sich
auskennen mit kohlestrom kultureller
aneignung länder gerechter sprache und
veganer ernährung mit spaß an
putschplänen und planungskomitee es ein
minenfeld für nicht akademiker und wenig
attraktiv für viele migrantische
jugendliche der klimaschutz sport selbst
zufrieden in seinem eigenen saft
aktivismus hat die bringschuld es ist
einfach so dass ich muss überzeugen wenn
ich etwas ändern möchte ich muss die
mehrheit dafür gewinnen damit das
politisch eine veränderung gibt und das
ist leider das problem auch bei einer
krise von dem man am main ich glaube
dass sie uns alle ja so hart treffen
wird oder schon trifft im gewann 7 eine
form von aktivismus die man bei frei des
for future in deutschland vergeblich
sucht aber der sich in südwestengland
mairose krieg verschrieben hat
ich finde es lächerlich dass sich die
umwelt und klimaschutz bewegung zu so
einer weißen oberschichten veranstaltung
entwickelt hat denn diese menschen sind
am wenigsten vom klimawandel betroffen
sind vor allem ethnische minderheiten
die arbeiterklasse aber auch frauen die
überall auf der welt deutlich mehr unter
dem klimawandel zu leiden haben als sie
und deshalb müssen wir uns den
klimaschutz von der weiße oberschicht
zurückholen damit der kampf gegen die
erderwärmung für diejenigen menschen
geführt wird die ihn am meisten brauchen
ihr kampfgeist fußt auf persönlicher
erfahrung seit frühster kindheit ist die
heute 20-jährige ornithologin draußen
unterwegs um die natur zu beobachten
und dabei merkt die tochter einer
muslime aus bangladesch schnell dass sie
anders ist
ich war nicht weiß meine mutter genauso
wenig und auf dem land habe ich nie
jemanden gesehen der so aussieht wie wir
als ich älter wurde der matte mir diese
leute kommen hier einfach nicht her also
habe ich mit leuten aus den asiatischen
und schwarzen communitys gesprochen und
die meisten nur wandern und spaziergänge
durch die natur mache das ist doch nur
was für weise
aus dieser irritation entsteht ein
bildungsprojekt back to nature natur für
alle sie veranstaltet camps für
jugendliche aus den großstädten in deren
alltag die natur keine rolle spielt
einfach weil sie weit weg ist und die
sich daher oft auch nicht sonderlich für
umweltschutz interessieren genau sie
lädt mairose craig ein und geht mit
ihnen raus in die wälder wiesen und
felder von somerset zu nachtfalter
fledermaus und nachtigall als batgirl
wird meyer so zum star der britischen
umweltschutzbewegung inklusive
ehrendoktorwürde denn das konzept geht
auf
manche der jugendlichen haben gar keine
lust hierher zu kommen und werden von
ihren müttern zu uns geschickt und das
ist dann besonders schön zu erleben wie
diese kinder in wenigen tagen auftauen
und merken augenblick das macht ja spaß
draußen in der natur zu sein deshalb
mache ich diese kämpfe wärme wenn man
wirklich dabei zusehen kann wie sich
diese jungs und mädchen in die natur
verlieben
die back to nature camps von burt girl
zeigen eine diverse hre klimaschutz
bewegung ist möglich durch die arbeit
von mairose craig entsteht in
großbritannien eine neue generation von
umweltschützern eine bewegung die
einlösen könnte was frei des for future
so gerne wäre eine gruppe die wirklich
für die ganze generation spricht
unabhängig von hautfarbe bildung und
vermögen